before we got started with our interview
we were just talking about
hiring people and you know people
reacting to the word no people reacting
to the word yes
you talk about that and and what that
means to you
yeah it's a little practice that i have
adapted and still
i think i play around with it um is to
when hiring someone or working with
someone or
going into any form of partnership or
place where i'll have to interact with
someone
i watch the way they respond to no and
even if i have to kind of strum up this
opportunity where i can tell them no
early on or
even if it's not a no it's like all
right give me a second
be patient whatever it is now in those
early stages you're not going to come
out and say these things you have to be
very very very perceptive
but just see how they react to that and
that is going to usually be a tell-tale
sign to
something about their character that you
might have to keep an eye on
and i say i play around with it because
i've actually seen this work
where i've never been wrong it's like
okay i saw the way they responded to no
even a year from then they're having a
horrible
situation with a co-worker or cast
member
or this or that and it comes down to
that one thing where i saw
they can't handle the no
or there's something that stirs up in
them from a no
and what i've seen is you know you can
like simplify it to be in childhood of
maybe mom told them no too much or maybe
mom told them
no not enough like ever or um
the teacher kind of was like well
they're a special kid let's let them do
what they want or whatever it is where
you had
freedom to do something that maybe
wasn't the most like healthy freedom
um where you needed some boundaries or
whatever it is um
some people are then able to mature
and seek out what they didn't get but
most people aren't
most of us just aren't that mature it's
just it's what it is so we're
we're going to fall into a space that we
were prone to from childhood
even if you don't see it in certain
moments you're going to see it when
things get bad
and with film things are going to get
bad at least one day
it's like the moment of truth like you
get to know people so much
after you film a film with people
everyone's like oh i love you and
whenever that happened you work with
somebody for a year and you love them
like
we can work at um i don't know a plant
amazon and
like i don't even know what are kids
names but you don't know anything about
a person you don't have any feelings for
the person but
the feelings are high because you're
very connected it's intimate spaces
there's long days
it's things that are uncontrollable like
weather and
finance and whatever things that you
just can't control so it
um it's going to stir up people in a
more
aggressive way than other vehicles
right so knowing that you need to know
how they respond to no
you need to know how they respond to an
obstacle
and you need to know how they're going
to interact
when they're upset about something or
not happy about something or didn't like
something
and the way that i find that out in a
very limited way
is to early on even sometimes before i
hire them is to tell them no
or wait or i don't really like when you
said that
how do they respond to that like scott
who i work with
he's very much a part of our company the
audacity
but also he directed the film
the film i last worked on and he is like
the best at
i don't really like that and he's like
oh why don't you like it that's his
response
that's awesome it's not how dare you
it's like no it's okay
like now let's talk i don't like that
you don't like that why
so but if someone's like i don't like i
don't like when you said such and such i
don't really like that idea and they're
like
they get sad that doesn't mean don't
work with them that just means be
mindful that this person may not
be able to take those moments and you're
gonna have to have those moments when
being creative
creatives have to feel confident to talk
and they can't be shut down by a no
so there's someone i'm working with now
even like brilliant
but the the nose or when the other
team's like ah what about this i don't
really like the idea what about this
you see them pulling back and kind of
putting a wall up
and digging into that a little bit more
they didn't have those opportunities to
kind of like
show themselves as a kid and be
validated by showing themselves it was
more like stay in your place
not right now not right now no stay here
so when that person starts to feel
comfortable and they say what they were
thinking
i need the team to be mindful now's not
the time to criticize
except what they just said and then
we're going to deliver this a little bit
more softer than i do i would with scott
scott you like no i don't like it all
right why like you know it's it's it's
being mindful of people being careful
with it but knowing that this is going
to be necessary
so if it's necessary for me to tell you
i don't like your idea let's find out
how you react to that earlier than
where i'm like oh my gosh we have a
deadline and this person literally will
not right now because now they just
having a mental breakdown because they
don't like their idea
because that can derail a whole project
so
finding that out early on in a fun
little way a very easy way that i i
have adapted to my own likes is
yes finding out how they respond to know
or wait or i don't like it
you